a 1900 kilogram truck has an initial
speed of 12 meters per second
the driver applies the brakes and the
truck stops in 3.1 seconds what is the
best estimate of the magnitude of the
average braking force on the truck pause
this video see if you can work this out
alright probably the simplest way to
approach this to say well we could
figure out the magnitude of the
acceleration the average acceleration on
that truck as it comes to a stop and
then we could use Newton's second law F
equals MA because we know its mass if we
know the mass and the magnitude of the
acceleration we could use Newton's
second law to come up with the magnitude
of the average braking force and they
just want us to estimate it and we can
see that these choices are pretty far
apart so an estimate will serve us well
so first let's think about the
acceleration the acceleration is going
to be our change in velocity over change
in time and so that's just going to be
our final velocity minus our initial
velocity in the numerator so our final
velocity is zero meters per second we
come to a stop
- our initial velocity that's 12 meters
per second and the convention that we'll
assume and it's typical is that if we're
moving to the right it's positive if
we're moving to the left its negative
and so it's moving to the right at 12
meters per second so we're subtracting
that positive velocity out so this is
our change in velocity over our change
in time
well 3.1 seconds elapses so over 3.1
seconds and so what is this going to be
approximately equal to well let's let's
see negative 12 over 3.1 is going to be
approximately 4 and once again I am
estimating it might be a little bit
closer - oh and it's going to be
approximately equal to negative 4 it
might be a little bit closer to negative
3.9 around there but I'll go with
negative 4 and then the units are meters
per second squared and now we use
Newton's second law to take this to
think about the magnitude of the braking
force which is going to be and this
makes sense that the acceleration is
negative that our velocity is in this
direction but our acceleration is in the
other direction it is slowing down we're
getting
lower and lower and lower velocities and
so our force is going to be in the same
direction our net force is in the same
direction as that acceleration is going
to be to the left so if we had a sign on
it it would it would be negative but we
just care about the magnitude so when we
think about Newton's second law we'll
also just look at the magnitude of the
acceleration so Newton's second law the
magnitude of the force needs to be equal
to the mass times the magnitude of the
acceleration so this is going to be
equal to this is let me write an
approximation here because I
approximated this it's gonna be
approximately 1900 kilograms times 4
meters per second squared I didn't feel
the need to write the negative there cuz
I just want to get the magnitude I care
about absolute value right now
so if I do this this is going to be
approximately what 7600 kilograms now if
I look at the choices I don't see 7600
but the closest one over here is 7400
and I feel good about that because the
real value here might be closer to
negative 3.9 m/s squared and if this was
3.9 right over here 3.9 times 1900 well
that gets us a lot closer to this right
here so I like this choice and all the
other ones are way off from our estimate